NBA superstar LeBron James make that la
Bron is taking his talents out west the
Los Angeles Times calls him LA's new
King this morning after the four-time
MVP agreed to a four-year 154 million
dollar contract with the Lakers James
thanked Cavaliers fans on Instagram
saying Ohio will always be my home and
Cleveland is offering a much different
farewell than the first time he left
eight years ago when LeBron James won an
NBA title with the Cavs in 2016 he
fulfilled a promise to his hometown fans
[Applause]
but after this year's crushing defeat by
the Golden State Warriors
James is once again leaving Cleveland
for a warmer climate this film will take
my talents to South Beach his infamous
decision to leave for the Miami Heat in
2010 left more than just a sour taste it
also left a trail of smoke as fans
burned his jerseys along Cleveland
streets so far the reaction this time
has been different softer blow than last
time but it still hurts
Cavaliers owner Dan Gilbert who called
James first decision to leave an act of
cowardly betrayal last night wrote
LeBron you came home and delivered the
ultimate goal we look forward to the
retirement of the famous number 23 Cavs
jersey now the biggest and brightest NBA
star will try to shine among the stars
of Hollywood a place he's already made a
name for himself in 2015 he starred in
the movie trainwreck where he spoke of
his love for Cleveland it's like when I
decided to go back to Cleveland I wasn't
totally sure dad's gonna welcome me back
man but they did they welcomed me back
with open arms and an open heart 154
million sounds like a good deal to me
but I love how Cleveland is responding
this yes when they said it still hurts
but I think they understand the decision
those of us who hoped he'd come
the Knicks are brokenhearted that hurts
- but we're cheering them on in LA I
think that's great yep